[Music]  today when I woke who would ever thought  that I would see killded ladies singing  while six nightingales flew by when I  strapped on my boots did I ever think  I'd see twenty jailbirds locked in cages  and a zebra with the keys  [Music]  when I looked at that bow lying cracked  on the shelf we did I think that an  inhabitant could ever be myself I've  lost track of what I knew but there is  one thing that I know Mary Poppins is  the one who makes it so it's  [Music]  and when it's time to dine your  waitresses bow fine as she's moving out  the orders to a chef quite elephantine  early bird special  every sign you pass said please don't  keep off the grass answer professor  Walton Roy you're Dalton  [Music]  [Music]